what type of music do you enjoy
listening to I listen to classical music
and mostly from the radio well that's
really easy and there's two real
important bands for me I'm more used to
be very much into Britpop as a teenager
so I always like they're people like
pulp and one of them is the Manic Street
Preachers because they are designed for
life and the other one is the super
furry animals and their music is just
amazing it's just it makes me bars and
it's it's what I listen to when I'm
driving probably not what I listen to
when I'm trying to calm down blue suede
I don't really have a CD player and I
definitely don't have an mp3 player or
an iPod or anything like that and I
listen to the radio quite often when I'm
working in my office what type of music
do you enjoy listening to oh man all of
it loads of music so classical favorite
piece probably Berlioz symphonie
fantastique I also like crusty things
like the Levellers and things like that
rock music Metallica fade black I listen
to mostly soul and R&B music from before
about 1978 folk music Marvin Gaye Stevie
Wonder Mull tail stuff that kind of
thing a wife a cheese I got folk music
bang called living a false Cove and I
like all kinds but I like bits of all
kinds if you know I mean electronic
music probably cosmic baby is one of my
favorite guys there fair bit heavy metal
all the way through to more
middle-of-the-road stuff like rbn Public
Enemy rap there's no one sets onra
there's no one set band or artist all
sorts I mean there really isn't much
there I haven't enjoyed I mean it like
every genre music it's gonna be good and
bad
I like good music is the only sort of
way I can category
like I've got thousands of albums I play
SingStar and rock band 3 so I like the
screamo and the metal but I also like
sometimes having it up with a bit of R&B
so it's it's a very mixed bag don't get
me started on that stuff what are your
favorite books ok
scientific my favorite book or let's say
the most influential book or one of the
most influential books I believe is am
the chemical bond by poling it really
did shape the way that chemists could
see chemical reactions and and the way
that atoms could interact with one
another so I think that really is one of
the most influential books so the nature
of the chemical bond by poling it's
really quite a difficult question
because I have lots and lots of books
thousands and very often I enjoyed the
book the time reading at the time
I don't read science books really
outside of that's out of here so I would
probably say my inorganic chemistry
textbooks when I was a student or in
fact at school I was very keen on a book
on physical chemistry by an American
called Walter J Moore was given to me by
my cousin Janet and I've still got it
but you can see from the dust I haven't
used it for some time I read books about
the origin of the universe things like
that so mostly popular science and then
obviously I read chemistry textbooks it
used to be the leading book in physical
chemistry nowadays they're much more
modern ones but it's still very good for
defining some things and from time to
time I do look at it despite the dust
rich at home the age of wonder it's all
about how science has changed and it's
moved away from the time of one person
at a bench making a discovery and having
a Eureka moment to the way it's done now
have teams of the searches and you have
to chip away at a problem for years to
get a solution one of my favorite books
is a book called molecules which changed
the world that's the most scientific
book it's by a guy called Casey nickel a
professor over at Scripps Institute and
a friend of mine actually Tamzin
Montaigne who's over in Crete as regards
ad the books I don't like oh I don't
read very much fiction I suppose I like
truth stories I like biographies rather
more graphic novels wanly is a series
called trans metropolitan by Warren
Ellis which is my all-time favorite and
if I could in an alternate reality be
spider Jerusem and get away with half
the things that he said to people I
would with regard to a non-scientific
book then I think my favorite book has
to be then the Hobbit because it's a
great story and you can read it on a
number of different levels and it's just
just a really good fun good story I look
forward to seeing the film non-science
books okay I'm a bit of a kid I like
things with wizards and vampires in them
I love Harry Potter and I loved why
light and I really like for more fiction
non science sort of area really like her
for the Pullman stock trilogy novels
I've done are quite like fire if we were
talking about novels quite like fantasy
novels so there's a raymandy Facebook
called magician which I really enjoyed
when I first read it about 20 years ago
or Lord of the Rings would be another
one I love that sort of slightly sci-fi
fantasy type of stuff one of the books
and this is a slight cheat but a book
which I'm very fond of is my father's
autobiography where he tells of his
childhood in Russia and I can show it to
you because you can't buy it anymore and
it's called the silver samovar if you
don't know what a samovar is you'll have
to look on Brady's other channel of
words of the world which will explain to
you but in general I like books that
tell me about interesting things that
have happen
in the past